portal Sky News let's just show you some
pictures coming into his from Paris this
is the class de la république now as
you'll know there's a huge climate
change conference going on there
starting today over the next two weeks
there was a planned demonstration a
climate change protest demonstration
that was supposed to happen today
hundreds of thousands indeed were
expected but it was canceled because as
you know there's a state of emergency in
the country at the moment after the
terror attacks in Paris two weeks ago we
don't exactly know what's happened here
but obviously riot police in place and
some smoke canisters have been set off
we know that instead of this protest
shoes were actually put down including
by at the head of the UN Ban ki-moon to
mark people's passions and how they felt
about I could see lots of shoes down
there on the floor at the moment
actually and the streets there and to
just as a mark of respect to mark the
fact that they couldn't hold the protest
but how strongly they felt about climate
change and how how much everybody there
suddenly the presses want to make sure
the world leaders do indeed some sign
some kind of agreement over the next
week's 150 world leaders expected over
the next day or so in Paris that these
protests at the moment with riot police